good morning everyone good morning menu
good morning cloud yeah some people are
saying they don't like good morning
Millennials and you don't have to say to
those people
good evening you know what to save those
people good morning can I say my joke
you know what to say I want to guess
good morning you're never gonna guess it
is it good morning [ __ ] you know it's
not even in that let me start again I've
heard a lot of people don't like good
morning Millennials but you know what
I'd say to those people
good morning Millennials is an issue of
mind over matter if you don't matter I
don't mind if you don't matter they said
they don't matter yes it feels for you
let us know in the comments even though
we're trying not to look at them I
didn't even have my phone today because
everyone just loves to give me negative
feedback and probably the most
circulated feedback I got was that stop
looking down at your phone and like
engage with your sister it's like you
don't look down at your phone and you
don't answer bike and I don't know that
I know the cauda
I don't know that like Taylor Diorio is
mad at me or something you know right so
it's it's a lose-lose however sometimes
you have to look down just in case for
having mic issues what we're sorry about
that yesterday we have a Saturday we
have some card or else so our mics don't
move around and you know what if they do
I'm just holding it up to my chin the
whole time because yeah I'm just maybe
she did better maybe we should get
Britney Spears like oh my god like that
what's-his-face what's that guy from
jello hell who's like an inspirational
speaker Tony Robbins yeah one of those
Tony Robbins head said I want mine to be
like bedazzled we should do that let's
invest okay look tell us the tousle
party at my house later this side even
so like you guys don't even see them and
we also look like we're taking off yeah
which two four I'm ready to go it feels
truly amazing I feel humbled I feel
blessed I feel grateful to be back in
black today I threw away those blue
jeans eat immediately immediately was
that from me girl
hell no I do not leave the south side
for this it feels so great to be back in
black jeans like I don't know what the
hell I was thinking you know it had a
momentary lapse that's why I said
yesterday I feel like I could be
pregnant and part of that is like where
you just like forget who you are
or maybe that's why you need to go to
brain camp you were just saying I was
just saying to Jackie how I need to go
to brain camp because Jackie made a
hilarious joke on our Instagram
yesterday about fell off a feed which is
apparently a joke we made on the show
months ago not even like a month ago and
I have no recollection of it and I was
just thinking like I have the worst
memory I don't even remember what
happened on Vanderpump rules last night
and I fully watched it but that's
because nothing really happened except
for Jackson Britney which we'll talk
about at the end in depth so that people
who don't watch a show can like tune
this out but I do really need to go to
brain camp Leslie Mann suggested it in
the best movie of all time called the
other woman the other woman thank you
that's why I need brain camp when I have
Jackie or is it pregnancy brain it could
be but like that like I'm totally
pregnant except for like the
insemination part donating an immaculate
conception yeah imagine I totally God
loved me I would totally I've got done
not you can't say [ __ ] like that
Oh God does love me for sure but you
can't say that yeah okay it's a girl
with no problem situation
I didn't disagree God loves ever
actually not everyone he definitely
doesn't like like internet trolls but he
took cares about that he just doesn't
love them well I don't think we've ever
spoken about God on the show no we had a
week without it which is weird because
we are we are god-fearing people oh my
god I hear the [ __ ] out of God yeah but
I we also love the [ __ ] out of God Oh
see what is like your relationship with
God I think this is like we need Carlos
when we should get him back next time in
order to feel closer to God or whichever
God you God - what's your cub my
relationship with God I think is good
and strong but it definitely absent
flows but like we see that a lot in the
Bible that like the people don't turn to
God until um yeah totally and and so God
doesn't get upset about that he
understands that he also wants you to
turn to him in those times of need no
totally and I just feel like when
everything's going wrong in your life
excuse me I'm talking to you look at me
Taylor sorry tell you the first person
who came to my mind didn't anything I
just feel my spidered okay good I just
feel like the cool thing about God is
like you can always go to him like orner
or her sorry women can do anything but
they're not God but God isn't in gender
but like that's true it's your capital
h-i-m Lady Gaga says it's capital H I am
so it's not it's genderless it's just a
pronoun
no it's genderless for sure but if I'm
gonna refer to it I'm the guy doesn't
have parts so he's have sex right so
he's genderless
this conversations about to take a bad
turn I think we should just capital
h-i-m it's just like so cool hey wow you
are on a roll today let me talk I was
gonna say that like when everything like
when you think life couldn't be getting
anywhere so if you really hit
rock-bottom like everyone in the world
hates you want to say mean things about
you on Twitter it's really like
gratifying to know that there's like
always someone you can turn to like it's
you can always turn to your family and
it but like you can always like and it
makes you feel a lot better like knowing
that like God has a plan do you know
what I mean it's not just anyone like
it's the almighty power superhuman them
so it's better than just happening like
a rogue friend who stuck who sticks by
you yeah let's go for brunch as always
this is the morning toast I'm Claudia
are a girl with no job I'm Jackie ah hey
Jackie O problems and we have a great
show for you a great show we're here to
deliver the Fast Five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of that morning toast or a
sip
char's charge the money that was coffee
you can take charge charge okay chart
here jars chars chars and cheese what
yeah today's an especially amazing day
because we have our gap of us justice
has been served
we are serving justice with our gobbles
justice for the god god is the best this
is is the morning breath it's not but
like I just wanted to say
we also Connor Dermot was our guest
yesterday oh yeah he wrote us a jingle
we didn't out we had practice writing
and we didn't ask him but he's singing
for us on the show but he wrote us a
jingle that is the perfect jingle
Felicia
sounds like the theme song of like a 50s
sitcom which is exactly what this is so
but if you didn't watch our previous
show we serve up justice on a daily
basis and it's only right that we have
the proper tools to allow us to serve
said justice so if you if there's anyone
you need just to serve for a for example
who's someone without always needs
justice David Foster right he was robbed
that's all this was saying justice needs
to be said for himself that's what we're
daytime okay our tapers mirrored though
so I can't marry us except doesn't this
table look like it's about to come to
life and be used it's an ancillary
character in the sequel
Cogsworth that you
honestly the spa's to which the oh yes
we're just so gilded we card it in gold
is that a song no it should be do you
want to write it any Connor Dermot back
here no I don't want us ignite now um do
you remember the jingle I hadn't stuck
in my head all morning it's like that
like you thought up now do Jackie and
Claudia that's how similar okay we're
gonna get into the Fast Five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast exciting time except during the
waiting period people are talking about
the toast that they were eating and like
doesn't do you need a havoc on otos I do
actually it's really good I don't need a
Vacarro toast I eat like Plato's I eat
smushed avocado on white bread with
nothing else on that's for sure maybe a
little salt some lemon
I feel like avocado toast is the perfect
snack for one like you actually need
energy because it has some carbs it has
the good kind of fat in avocado people
say salt isn't a spice like herb like or
seasoning they say salt isn't a
seasoning what is it no they're meaning
like it doesn't add flavor yeah but like
it was a joke seasoning I use right but
there's a joke that like white people
only season their stuff with salt I'm
like honestly I fully fit that sorry
about that potato salad thing I think
okay
so honestly I don't own one or I'm
seasoning my food like salt I hate
pepper
I don't hate pepper but it does get
second in YouTube yeah I like pepper on
an avocado toast it a little kick but
they where we're going for lunch today
has a kata just we're gonna get it
Amador's region oh oh right okay I was
hoping we were gonna go to Fagan Olive
which is made me take her place you do
so Housewives intently and LuAnn when
yes it's my they've multiple locations
all like near where I want to be except
one across they need you doing in like
the Flatiron area yes but there's one
across the street from bloomingdales I
always need to be around there there's
one like a downtown meet I feel like
there are so many good restaurants
across this you can bloom emails
including 40 Karen in bloomingdales yeah
no need to leave right we should go the
ones there no we have to be downtown -
okay
we've been very busy day of meetings you
guys we have a lot of
exciting things happening um oh good
good transition yeah we have two really
big things happening today one that
we're announcing today one that we'll be
announcing later in our group in the
morning toasters which is to be because
if you're in it you already know this
first announcement the first
announcement is that I have booked for
more shows at Caroline's on Broadway
so yesterday wait yesterday I wrote like
I was being annoying I'm like Stiga
project and some person was like is it a
one-woman show on Broadway and I'm like
yes I don't know how to describe it
because it really is stand-up but like
I've never really considered myself a
comedian but when I did the last two
shows I was totally comedian vibes I was
like basically also were one-woman show
vibe right very like I don't know what
to call it
like the industry's calling it like a
variety show some people are calling it
stand-up some people are calling it like
an evening with girls no job some people
are calling it like a game night and now
I just had to officially title it a
one-woman show on Broadway or what about
the Claudia monologues no because I can
only think about vaginas for sure but
embrace it well therefore shows May 10th
and 11th the early show a late show
one's a Friday night so if you need to
come in from out of town you could spend
the weekend it's gonna be great you can
do meet-and-greet you can do regular
tickets if you just want to come like at
the lowest level it's 25 bucks it's
gonna be really good time I hope
everyone can make it I really hope they
sell cause like I'm having terrible Pitt
and like Ben's okay Ben said a call like
with the first show I knew people were
gonna die it's only like it's a 300
person theater so like I knew but I was
being annoying I'm like oh people buy it
bends like you're that girl who likes
Teddy for the test and always gets an A
and then like everyone's circling after
that you only do that for so long so
yeah you're the girl who cried yeah
because now it's for shows and like
that's basically impossible to sell out
I don't think so I think I think you
could do it and also like are there any
reviews posted about your other shows
because they were unreal I don't know
where would someone leave a review oh
yeah I don't know I think myself a
yellow page actually no I need to stop
opening myself up for criticism because
I can't handle it I really can't I know
you but then we also have a show related
update that'll be coming out later in
the group say it's a really really
awesome site people asked for it's a lot
of what people have asked for it's a
company but it's not much because that
takes a long time but we are working on
it but it has to do with merch and
you're just happening you guys you know
that the merch couldn't happen Murphy
couldn't happen before because we had so
many like legal restrictions we are free
of those now clearly you know we are
bird i want you flying away okay I don't
know about all this
I don't know where my home is home and
that was my favorite song girl I know
you would like stand nelly furtado yeah
stop before it's stabbing was even a
thing and another exciting announcement
coming today and the toasters groups so
make sure you're a part of it and make
sure you answer the questions in like a
real creative fashion because I read
every single answer and honestly those
answers are shady or fishy or just like
rubbing me the wrong way if you do pick
just a few minutes ago yeah if you
joined Facebook just a few minutes ago
you probably won't get any cuz you're
probably trolled trying to snitch in our
group and it's like snitches Hey it's
just eight when will people understand
like if you're snitching like thank you
yeah cuz you don't know it just it's
just like Erica James caption on her
Instagram yesterday haters are just fans
they don't know it yet yeah her haters
were fast okay anyways let's get into
the past night story yes that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast which I
hope you have because now it's 10:43 and
I have any secured and you need to
kickstart your metabolism mind totally
first up man this feels like old news
ready I know how a kardashian baby
girl's name revealed welcome True
Jackson Thompson it's almost like she
did it to spite us cuz it happened right
after the show like now we have to wait
a whole 24 hours and like no one even
cares she keeps doing that but maybe
it's cuz she's on like la time yeah and
she just doesn't know who we are which
is very possible I don't know she's
probably never heard no it's possible
it's possible that she's never heard no
it's more than likely ok this name I
didn't realize it's a family name Kris
Jenner put on her Instagram that it was
her grandfather's middle name it's like
a family name I guess the baby's name is
gonna be Thompson I don't like the name
it doesn't make any sense and it's just
all too ironic for me and like I see
just ironing the jokes like I'm look I
was over the jokes before they even
happened like true he lied no we did
even like I don't think he ever even
read it but you know as they say a lying
volume by omission it's so I think he
knew she knew they all knew we just
found out yeah I just want to see a
picture of the baby I'm really happy for
Chloe like I just feel like there's
nothing
whenever I talk about like babies or
fertility like it makes me so happy I
just like love babies and she just like
one and one for so long and I'm just
really happy that she like finally got
what she wanted are you okay
trying to hold back a sneeze do it no no
no I don't sneeze IKEA like I need a
tissue and the shofar blows knees like a
mine no like my Caesars are like a
shofar because I can't once I sneeze I
just blow it all out because I know I
can't hold anything does that - yeah you
gotta get it out or if I don't have a
tissue
I just know don't even give me a tissue
please like disgusting or icy as I hold
it in but then everyone else I'm so bad
for you and I'm blowing my brains out
yeah then I'll need to go to brain camp
with you Ken - everybody should do like
a seminar a brain camp totally and we
should I don't know who we would bring
in like what I just learned like the
media that I'm consuming it's definitely
taking a toll on my brain and I need to
figure something out I need to do yoga
or something but like no it's not that
maybe you know what does help even
though this is such a lame answer but
reading I do read maybe cuz you play
like some I have there are some apps
that are like green that's what I was
thinking yeah I once stayed one and I
felt a little bit or like play some
Sudoku or do a crossword puzzle okay
fine anyways happy I'm really happy for
Chloe would you like she's wanted to be
a mom for so long here she is being a
mom and like that's more important than
her in Fidelis baby daddy I love that
word is that a word
no but it's aware now it's so delicious
in infants in fiddle Isha's in delicious
baby daddy yeah I'm happy for honestly
I'm really like around the corner from
China in this whole story I said I'm at
think my brain has reached a capacity
for how much I can care about this one
couple however I don't think Chloe
Claudia I don't think Chloe is
perpetuating this story like she's
trying to annoy us with it like the
Hollywood like he's just trying to
ignore it we don't know what happy - I'm
happy to ignore it you want to move on
to the next story because you discovered
but what is so crazy
ryuk Harry's ex manager claimed sexual
harassment singer was always naked okay
here are the deeds this is what she's
claiming moriah determine oh so you
would probably recognize this woman from
Mariah's world if you ever caught a
glimpse yeah but you probably don't I
don't know it was on before Kardashian
so sometimes either though sometimes you
were absolutely yeah
next week on Brian's world so excuses
right Mariah Carey's former manager
claims she was repeated sexually she was
heatedly sexually harassed by the singer
because Mariah was constantly naked in
front of her t is TMZ has learned but
Mariah calls the allegation quote
baseless we broke TMZ burke the story
stellastot per file docs putting carries
team on notice a lawsuit is coming and
now we know what's behind it all we're
told Stella's claiming Mariah rarely
wore clothes around her and was not only
naked but did sexual things in Stella's
presence we're told salable also alleged
Mariah has a substance abuse problem and
fails to take her meds for bipolar
disorder it suffers from a disorder this
is crazy
just last week Mariah revealed she was
diagnosed with bipolar disorder in 2001
but Stella's claiming that's just a
small part of her problems further
Stella will claims she was unfairly file
fired in the middle of her three-year
contract and is still do a ton of cash
she's giving Mariah an opportunity to
make things right want to see what I
look like today okay you look good like
my hella is poppin look like a tree
sorry I really didn't mean to interrupt
you that's what you did but I didn't
mean to interrupt you but it's exactly
what I did okay so these are the claims
okay I'm writing them baseless which is
a fantastic word yeah I never the
stories like this are so hard for me to
comment on because like I'm never gonna
victim lame but this is just wild and
like I just don't see it like when when
I saw Harvey Weinstein like in a robe
like I could picture it do you know what
I mean I can I can see Jen Schneider
like licking the toes of young children
I see it I don't see Mariah Carey like
masturbating in front of her nothing
like I just don't see it yeah I also
don't see her walking around naked
because I feel like she's very bit like
body just conscious yeah I agree
no but also her and this woman Stella
had like beef even on the show like
Stella was fired rehired there's clearly
some bad blood there so I'm sure she
liked but I darted to blame it's hard to
really know what's what and you know
it's just so upsetting it's like we're
never gonna find out what's what we
weren't there there's no tape no but
maybe you could ask them of your fancy
friends I might I just I don't see it
but at the same time I respect her
decision to come forward
very brave it's so tough like to it to
be a spokesperson it is for my
generation I think oh now we're talking
about you yes sorry I
find that I fit I miss anyway I find
that I fail at being a good spokesperson
like all the time
really what do you want to speak up
about here's her chance no no not that I
when I comment on other things like I'm
always doing the wrong thing like okay
ready
someone left a comment on my Instagram
about what we said about Miranda Lambert
I'm like it really made me feel bad
about to her yeah I mean obviously the
girl had to see something nasty about me
too which was like so not nice and like
she could have gotten her point across
because like I kind of understood it
that basically like Miranda is like out
of all the country singers like she's a
real country like she grew up in like
South Dakota and like she speaks for all
the girls who like grew up on dirt roads
and like not like the girls were like
grew up in Dallas do you know any yeah
like and and then she was like and not
the girls take uber to work every day
and I'm like ok why'd you have to throw
it in my face I don't even take him over
to work every day so like please right
we carpool yeah
however then I got a bunch of things
about Miranda Lambert and I didn't get
anything that disagreed with he doesn't
like it she goes back to her small town
and she always like goes back like smug
and like not cheery and when she was
with Blake Shelton he was always so nice
to the people and not cheery
where do come up with these words and
you would still be here to say you're
like all crazy vocabulary I'm like you
use it like it's normal but you didn't
know what the word conjecture man
yesterday I know I don't know you must
have missed that one yeah it was like
that I missed that day event yeah I mean
sorry
so we took a no but anyways they were
saying that but when Blake would go with
her back to the dirt road he was always
not smug to be very cheery thought--
just one dirt road it's just like a town
with dirt roads I was just you know just
doing conjecture no no no I totally see
Blake being like a man of the people
um I still hate Miranda Lambert I'm
something like making fun of her but
like someone's calm I got I understood
and I do understand how maybe like we
love like country pop singers you know
glitz glam blah blah blah but she's just
like her little tin man you know yeah
the worst song of all time is different
than some of the other singers she's no
Carrie Underwood I read a Twitter read
oh and then I have something I want tell
you I read a Twitter thread of like a
bunch of country fans talking about them
winning I'm Miranda winning and like
they agreed with us like they're like
I've heard a Kelsea Ballerini and Mara
and Marcia's songs
100 more times and I've ever heard tin
man yeah and it's a female vocalist of
the year like whose vocals were the most
honestly it was Maren Morris I agree or
maybe she'll get next year because like
what she did
the middle has brought country to like
uh-huh she literally is the female
equivalent of the yodeling Walmart boy
in terms of what they've done for
country music soup's also Carrie
Underwood Carrie Underwood she did that
years ago you know some say nowadays and
I'm sure Carrie Underwood one when she
did it yeah
something else I want to talk about is
Rolling Stone the country division of
wrote an article about how the ACMs
didn't honor route 51 enough and Myra
Morris like got into them on Twitter and
I just want to show you she was like
please don't speak about like a fan hood
that's not yours and when we're just
trying to help everyone move on I guess
like what early told said was that they
didn't confront it head-on and up and
like they didn't make it like emotional
enough whereas like the ACMs vibe was
like they wanted to honor it but they
didn't want to they wanted to be
everyone to be able to move forward in
like a healthy way and the he has music
to do that I see both sides but like why
reading an article about it like please
please also leave country music like the
country music award show that followed
time is this was it the CME's well yes
that's what the article said but the
article said that the CMAs gave every
person on the red carpet media like a
specific rules to not ask about the
shooting so they they took it too far
no but then they did a whole tribute
during the show I don't know it's hard
to put like those already sounds my
personal some of them were there and
they like they'll talk about it in their
own way they don't need to answer your
questions on the red carpet trying to
get clicks yeah like they don't need to
do that they can talk about it in their
own way and something all day and it's
such a touchy subject so it's not your
call how people talk about it also like
the only reason the only reason what the
ACMs didn't do that justice is by not
giving me award to dear hey yeah
but they gave it to Jason Aldean when
he's so clearly like did not desire hear
his speech how was it I told you it
wasn't good yeah he mention like my room
51 people and those that's so sad maybe
take that everyone bitched out to us
no he posted an interim the view outside
his Las Vegas window with this long
caption like how he was so excited it's
a Vegas open up the window see what his
view was is if I mean the mountains is
gonna be a pool and it was I had a lot
of room if you want and like first they
want him to like shut the curtains cuz
when she depressing but having to like
look at it in the faces like how we get
stronger he who's really really a power
above the Dickerson's love the dickerson
alright what we got next
Lamar oh and I'm response to Kanye
West's touching tweet about his 2016
recovery
the tweet was really cute how and really
randomly time yeah was it no I mean
Kanye West is in the middle of a mental
breakdown so nothing is surrounded is he
yes again Kim like props him up like
weekend at Bernie's like a prop him up
put glasses on him for like a picture
every month but he's like not okay wait
where'd you hear that everyone knows
that I really I feel like everyone
thinks he's going through mental
breakdown but he's fine and they're fine
and everything's fine no he's definitely
going through something really yeah well
he said he had tweeted earlier that it
meant so much to him to do his say Pablo
thing and Lamar because he used to play
the album for Lamar while he was
unconscious and so it really all came
full circle I really wanted like a happy
ending for Khloe and Lamar not after
what Lamar said no no he totally ruined
that when she was on her fifth or sixth
basketball player he knew it was over
please man when you are near fifth or
sixth crack pipe that's what I know like
it's not gonna work out but like after
the incident I know that like she took
care of him she bought in my house like
she did everything like I think they
could have made it work back then no you
can't make it work with someone he's
being propped up we can up ernicio for
sure a Kimmel if he's not dead like he's
wild
no he got he's a cat but does that mean
it could happen any more times I don't
know
okay so what did Lamar respond to this
week glad I could be there for you bro
like you came through for me it was big
stage to be on after everything I went
through but it was worth it at Kanye you
know like that Lamar he was there you
don't have Twitter right
but I feel like they can't ever reach
him my kids even have a phone right
Jamie died he's young Jamie from the
show from drugs and still Lamar does his
thing right I'm like where's Lamar out
today is he sober I don't know I don't
think so I think he's in a brothel and
people are like trying to get Khloe and
Lamar back together no I better chip
that I'd rather her take Tristan Mac I'd
rather take French Montana he was a good
guy for sure and like why did they break
up
I think like he was too like he's
already guy okay but he was less party
than clearly Lamar Lamar or Tristan you
know I never got taught motorboating and
all the sisters really liked him yeah he
was like I think he was perfect he was
definitely like her rebound guy he was
perfect for that time in the Hamptons
yeah she like literally tried to
Atlantic City to go out like I was going
out hard and I think that's what she
needed
yeah now she's a mom so that lifestyle
probably wouldn't work for her I hate
that French Montana was teething too
earthy wing but I don't think that was
true no she was like on tour with him
yeah whatever was question ask me who
would you set Khloe up with I don't know
maybe like a retired basketball player
maybe like someone who's not horribly
Jabbar he's old
yeah like a businessman I don't know
she's they don't like when Tyler Perry
is he not married he totally is loose no
I think a retired like low-level shot
and be a player shot low level Shaq's
Charles Barkley definitely has like hoes
in different area codes no he's a fiance
does he I don't know does that even mean
anything anything no everyone she
doesn't even mean anything anymore
everyone cheats except for me that
should be the guys to me Oh everyone
cheats except for our checker he
probably does too but I believe it yeah
did you see they named their baby boy
Forrest
yes I just like she's the best life yeah
I feel like you're not supposed to say
that you're not suppose to be like
jealous of other people's lives cause
like you never name God so like punish
you and they give you a terrible life no
but I'll see you everyone has struggles
my biggest fear not every single person
deals with stuff I just feel like Jesse
James Decker struggles or like not that
bad I mean May it's from your mouth to
God's ears I just really am like jealous
I forgot you guys if anyone's like oh
what was today's like show called God
the one about God yeah
do you know that that's a friend thing I
know you do yes I like how they did that
and I watched your clip I don't know how
I missed this on York ones Instagram of
the Alec Baldwin Massapequa episode
which is my favorite episode
yes very I see none yeah Meza Pete and
the best part about guys from s Alec
Baldwin is from Massapequa I know that
from comedians Amir to copy even though
his episode was it's fun he's very like
above it all yeah also he's not a
comedian
anyway she acts in his daily life like
yeah he'll the waitress is talking to
him and he's like acting what's my next
line but she doesn't know that there
it's
obviously it's like crazy anger like
needs to pretend he's normal right
whatever what's the next ory next right
Tamra judge asks quote everyone to pray
for her husband as he Eddie s he
undergoes heart surgery very very
Saturday family it's like really serious
really yeah well hard really really
serious yeah and I think that they are
come because they always somewhere on
st. Patrick's Day how do you get like
sick when like you own the gym do you
know I mean yeah let's see as I sit in
the waiting room cameras caption this is
her caption his fourth heart procedure
in four months
what as I sit in the waiting room I need
everyone to pray for Eddie judge another
cardioversion fourth heart procedure in
four months and I want my healthy
husband Mac
hashtag power of prayer from your mouth
to God's ears you guys okay I really
like I hope they're not filming do you
know any mean yeah for a quarter couple
of surgeries in four months four but so
it's been going on for four months so
they're definitely like this is
definitely her storyline is you know for
sure but the Tamra if Tamra's daughter
begging her to not be on the show won't
get Tamara to stop being on the show a
minor heart surgery is not gonna get
time--where from not being on the job I
don't know what could happen that Tamara
wouldn't be on the show
besides are getting fired nothing in the
world could happen I think what could
happen is that the tides turn and well
they accepted the Mickey back but this
it could be a Jill zarin's syndrome
where their tides turn and everyone's
team Vicki and Tamra and Shannon still
never happen but that'll never happen
Tamra's so smart but do you think that
who would get fired first Tamara Ricky
what if it came down to it but every
installment of the franchise has in hoji
and Tamara's not no G doesn't matter so
but I don't know I think that sets a bad
precedent
I feel like Annie will keep Vicki for as
long as he possibly can I'm telling Tom
they have no reason to fire Tamara she
remains in the drama but not so much so
that she becomes isolated and she's
always friends with like the cool people
yeah she's really smart she's a she's a
she's a Kyle she's a strategist
she's a coyote her temper she'll never
got fired they have no reason to ever
fire her but I was just saying like her
husband is going through like a very
serious illness her daughter beg
church's like being normal
there's nothing that when it could
happen that Tamara would not be on the
show for I agree with that but she's
it's she's a businesswoman like you have
to think it's not just thirsty for fame
like they make some of them hundreds of
thousands of dollars per episode
there's millions per season good
so I somewhat heart surgeries aren't
gonna pay for themselves totally but
like at some point like your family
comes before money I mean like when your
daughter literally won't let you come to
your graduation yeah I hope they don't
put this on the season one because like
to take your privacy during this time to
because that's not why we bought your
house I'd say yeah it's depressing it's
depressing like I just want to see the
glitz and the glam like I don't want to
pit
I want the limos yeah I want the homes I
don't want I want the trips I don't want
the piss
do you like the tricks love the trips I
love the trips when I feel like I like
the ladies like when rouhani went to
Mexico I was like loving all the ladies
in the house looked amazing like I
wanted to be there yeah like the OC
ladies they like don't really even like
each other and like I don't I didn't
want to be in Dublin and it takes like a
few days for them to like come together
yeah like I really wanted to be in
Montana with Real Housewives of New York
when they went on with Heather yeah and
also like when they went when they went
to Mexico it looked like the most the
best road trip of all time but like so
when it's a bunch like when the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills no well yeah
when they went to Berlin I don't want to
be there but the Beverly Hills
housewives talk about their trips like
so unfamiliar
like the way they talk about Hong Kong
well because the Beverly Hills girls are
actually rich and I feel like traveling
with the show was probably like a lesser
experience in terms I know for sure but
like they don't fly private
whereas when most ladies convocation
they do but when Erika is playing when
their domestic I think they fly private
the show would prefer them to buy
private I'm sure I don't know but I'm
just saying like I think it's like a
step down but I think the real house in
New York they fly Lux I mean they travel
lux but they also travel lux when
they're on the show it's like the same
level of luxury okay that's just a
thought like when the real house of
Atlanta went to Africa like that looked
amazing I'm gonna tank willow like I
would have been down to go there but
like I don't know some of the trips like
don't do it for me
I agree with that like Barcelona I was
not down we all said to Lana and that
shitty like motel I love when they ever
run fights over accommodations except
Antonio me is it's just super real
but it's still real like that's really
what happens yeah just let me just say
I'm just like trying to think it when
it's us like yeah who's there Ramona
well you are because you this is the
thing like Jackie when we were on
vacation like there certain things she
cares about like on an airplane like
Jackie will give up her Isle or my
middle aisle
I'll shoot in the middle where I was
like I would do anything in the world
I'd rather sit on the floor like I can't
sit in the middle but then when it comes
to rooms like I'm happy to share a bed
with Olivia like a shared bed with
someone where's like when it comes to
rooms like you need your own space yeah
or like you would share bathroom yeah
you wouldn't so like everyone has their
thing everyone has their needs but I
definitely I'm humming in sin certain
areas but then I give up in the other
areas where I'm not him even it's like I
gave snitch I would never ever forget
this
I gave snitch my aisle seat on her
flight home from Israel although I sat
in the middle in Economy and the flight
home from Israel I literally almost
broke my net yeah so that's just the
kind of sister that I am very very
giving okay final story Amazon workers
are peeing into bottles to save time as
an investigator who's investigating this
Amazon warehouse staff are peeing in
bottles because bathrooms are hundreds
of yards away okay I kind of understand
that yeah one X worker said staffers
fear they'll get into trouble for taking
too long away from the job the Amazon
warehouse in question measures 700,000
square feet and some of the 1,200
workers face a ten-minute quarter-mile
walk she lets on the ground floor of the
four-story building okay like didn't we
do like building codes back in the
nineteen I'm sorry the Triangle
Shirtwaist Fire rhaggy if I can't put a
wall up in my apartment
Amazon shouldn't need to have more
bathrooms yeah like I don't get the the
relevance like they're always like the
codes the codes are always infringing
upon us and they're supposed to be there
to help us and protect us
we're like they never helped but protect
us and like up instance we're like there
should be a code instilled there isn't
and I hate hearing bad things but I am
some because I'm in love with them and
like I don't care that they're ruining
brick-and-mortar stores like they get me
everything I need in a moment's notice
and like I just don't want anything bad
ever happening to Amazon I'm like this
is not okay you know what I just ordered
from Amazon which is like you could only
get on Amazon a bag of all pink
starburst
you know I just order an Amazon that you
can really only get on Amazon a double
chin like exerciser that I really like
something do you think it's working you
know that was funny content yeah man
Amazon's the best like I just I know
everyone like hates em cuz like they're
ruining mom-and-pop bookstores like who
gives a [ __ ] you can get your book five
seconds sooner and for free like
basically I but sometimes you just like
want to go to a Borders like maybe like
once a year
maybe you're like meeting someone for
coffee or like I want to get the book
that day because I'm going on vacation
the next day okay and so the fact that
there really is no well they're opening
Amazon bookstores and Amazon is now that
a joke no they're doing it for real I
heard that they were opening these book
serves as a joke like that where the
hell did you hear that I know I think
Zach and I still have the book store
yeah as a joke
that's an expensive joke yeah I know but
they're doing it to be like mom and that
is why they're doing it but not as a
joke like everyone says they're ruining
brick-and-mortar
okay here's brick-and-mortar yeah as a
joke I just like I'm definitely here for
Amazon they definitely scare me a little
bit and like the one time of year that I
could want to go to a Borders and like
sit between the shelves like I'll make
up for that with all the money I'm
saving and all the efficiency I have you
know yeah I need to get some books for a
trip next week I have so we are out of
town next week so I don't remember one
night and we'll be back to back on the
air the following Tuesday but we're out
from Monday to Monday so we don't want
to leave you guys content list because
like we did that for a month I'm like
everyone like almost died so what we're
gonna do is we're obviously not able to
do a live show cuz we can take our
studio with us on our trip but we are
gonna be doing podcasts and basically
it's a big trip Ben is going zach is
going Olivia and Margo's axe Olivia's
going like everyone's going and we are
going to do a podcast episode every day
with a guest so Snitch will be aghast
been will be again Sean the toast
John the toast leg on the toast live on
the toast ban on ban on the toast that's
on the toast said I'm some fum the sacks
on the toast a so it's gonna be great
premium content let me deliver I've seen
them before I really bring fast five
stories but we're gonna get into the you
know the heart of our sisters harbors
and friends yeah like you've seen been
like you've never seen him before but
that was like eight months ago so Jude
that was the surface right what's what's
been going on what's changing madness oh
no he did yeah it was before the
mortgage yeah and we were talking about
like you know his premarital jitters
there were none so it's gonna be really
good well so it'll be available as
podcasts only we'll be back on Tuesday -
it's gonna be like premium content yeah
I'm excited to like see our sisters
others and friends like you've never
seen them before
I know I hope they open up to us you
know you know how it's like when Andy
Cohen does plead the fifth it's like
people feel like they have to answer
yeah I feel like there's something about
like doing a podcast where people feel
like they have to answer I feel exactly
Pierrot Olivia Zack is like really gonna
open Assam yeah I'm really excited I'm
really excited too so make sure you're
subscribed to the podcast because that's
what's going on next week
good morning toast in the podcast app if
you want to leave a five-star review say
something nice about your favorite host
that'd be cool too but yeah no pressure
no pressure um yeah so Amazon workers
are peeing in battles that's disgusting
that is disgusting it's ugly violates
some hello building codes something
where those codes when you need them and
like they can't get some more toilets it
just seems inhumane and what about a
porta potty another girl's blog is
better than a bottle no but like just
install some toilets
yeah there's so much money Jeff Bezos
maybe if he put in more toilets so he'd
go back down to number two yeah which is
probably why he doesn't want to do it
okay we are also gonna be having to a
banner pumper walls it's oh yeah on a
monday nights and wait I watched
American Idol some of it I sell to watch
her ass I can't believe I've been
sitting on it they did the most amazing
thing they have like the top ten I guess
who it was performed with real artists
so have them performed with Lea Michele
bebe Rexha the guy who sings from the I
wanna be somebody yes who else was there
Colbie Caillat and it was amazing
I'm recently obsessed with bebe Rexha
because of meant to be and she's saying
meant to me but this country singer who
has the most amazing voice he's like
this deep raspy like George Strait bad
it was so good and then Lea Michele
saying defying gravity with
what's-her-name Ava
azam azam some of them and it's like
every time Lea Michele sings defying
gravity it's always in a duet because I
still gets its wings yeah but it's like
why can't she ever sing it alone because
she has a duet when she was singing it
there has to be also like Glinda and no
it's a one-one song is it yeah
it's literally the best song she was so
good I [ __ ] loved Lea Michele I just
think that that's a two-episode American
Idol was such premium content oh and
Katy Perry's out of her mind in a good
way no really remember we watched we
were like oh she's so cute she's gotten
out of control she is I don't want to
say anything bad but like she must be on
like I don't even know Jackie she was
being said
she ripped her pants and was showing her
ass to the audience and she had someone
like taping up her ass she was being
crazy she was acting like I swear to God
like a toddler you have to much feared
being crazy I will watch but she I said
should I said she's been crazy that
makes me sad because I'm so excited to
be liking her again I know I was even
gonna listen to her album witness yeah
because remember she used to be my young
singer No prism was the best album of
all time the best album of all time like
firework is the greatest song of all
time she's to me my favorite thing or
like loved her more than Kelly Clarkson
more than anyone and then she obviously
lost her mind and coming her and cut her
hair she was like Samson like she lost
all of her likability anyways then
watching Meghan I don't just say brought
me back to the good old days but no
she's gone off a cliff I have no idea
what's going on saying I would love to
judge a Luke Bryan actually although
stuck to my like Lionel Richie he seems
like so they're like celebrities like I
feel like sometimes they're like like
there's no person there's no there there
yeah she's like this she'll totally
there and I would love to know what he's
seen from Katy Perry like he's probably
seen a lot I feel like he probably likes
her but I feel like if you know her you
would like her but it's just like when
you don't know her you need to see her
antics you're like I know everyone we
know that like knows her like swears
that she's like amazing yeah it's just
one person yeah but he's really good
friends yeah and he like swears he's
like a good person he's also like a good
judge of character yeah I could see him
being like not like the healings that
was like good celebrities yeah
yeah okay now to talk about his phallus
plunge oh my god you guys Elon Musk
follow Ben and like I'm a little jealous
but I'm really happy any only people
people people I said no and he followed
and like I was in the mad at her place
and like in literally ruin my matic here
just a tub and and like he wasn't that
excited I guess like we're excited cuz
like he loved us but like for Ben it's
like some guy was like a couple million
dollars
no no he's like he's the Thomas Edison
of our generation like Ben could if he
plays his cards right like be a beta
tester of the Hyperloop yeah or like of
a car a flying car no a self-driving car
I was actually made a 20-byte Ben you
might not want him to be a beta tester
of a self-driving car yeah that's what
people talk yeah I mean Vanderpump rules
honestly like such a slow episode I
this is what I learned I'm literally
[ __ ] hate Patrick he's so rude that's
seen in her kitchen was so uncomfortable
however when he remembered the last time
he was on he was being rude Stassi like
came to his defense even though they
were already broken up she said on
Twitter like he really is a great guy
like he's not like that so I always keep
that in the back of my head but like
that the editors might be editing him
this but how can you make him be a dick
like he was new but like maybe like the
context of what she's saying like me
sarcastic comments aren't coming off but
then by her facial expressions even if
it's just editing like okay I'm
convinced
she could do so much better and she is
yeah her boyfriends and she seems like
so happy happy and my she's you know
what she is like she's really pretty and
like she's like a cool girl but she's
like not she's kind of like a nerd and
like she's into like he's Game of
Thrones she's me or she's weird and when
her boyfriend is also a very bizarre if
you see him on its remand they're
literally perfect for each other
no I know and I feel like she's it
really like she when she started the
show she was like cool [ __ ] yeah etc
she wasn't like weird or like having
these quirks and like now she's really
into like no I mean though to murder but
she's in bracelets I was like she's
obsessed with lollol and the way that
we're obsessed with greatest showmen and
like she just nerds out I totally and I
feel really happy for her I really hope
that he feels seems great oh my god did
you see on her Instagram story she
filmed him watching her talk about how
she would murder her boyfriend if he
cheated on her with an ice pick and then
let it melt to their weapon and he was
like shook obviously but it's just a
great way to get to know someone you
know they're really cute I hope that he
films and I hope he said cool about like
Patrick was just too uptight and then
like he was so anti the show and like
then the show proved to him like why he
didn't to be on cuz they made him look
like a villain right so he was like I
was right but it meant scene where she's
talking to Brittany and she her hair's
in the side part when they're at the
pucker & pout party and she was like
talking like so she didn't sound like
herself I don't know if that's what she
said she's drunk
yeah but I guess we've never really seen
her have I tried to have a
heart-to-heart when she's drunk but she
just sounded like a wise older woman
she's very wise she is because she's
lived she's been she's lived yeah
like don't forget you like the first few
seasons were like rougher right and that
and then ex-boyfriend and then when
should you order yeah and when she
wasn't on the show that was crazy yeah
and then she came back and she
to like eat some [ __ ] oh man she to
eaten that hummus he's been like humble
but she's also like still funny so I
think it's cool how like she has the
most followers about anyone on the show
and like she literally wasn't even on
season and almost got kicked out
she and yeah and she is the most
favorite I always tried to see I think
she because of her podcast
yeah but her podcast is only so popular
because of her you know
I think she has the second most yeah
she's at like 900 okay like she know who
the most fallen housewife on social
media is as of like a year ago when I
read this statistic it could be wrong um
I used to know it's shocking hey who
would you think I wouldn't think Erika
Jayne because she's very you know maybe
like Lisa man remember one of the oh
geez okay Lucy Bennett my blue dress for
interconnection and she does not post
premium content kandi Burruss what and
it kind of makes sense because she's a
celebrity outside of housewives like
with xscape and with Ed Sheeran song but
she also has like such a successful
business kandi-coated pleasure whatever
it is she makes sex toys you know that
she wrote thing you know she wrote shape
of you know she didn't this she gets
money from it now because it sounds so
similar to one of her songs or she wrote
no she didn't write it but her she is
sued so she's like successful in her own
right
she wrote TLC's like she would have had
a hundred K like without the show and
her business candy-coated whatever is so
successful like on from a monetary
standpoint then also from like a social
media standpoint so it makes K makes
sense and and Atlanta is the most
watched franchise that's shocking it's
shocking but like then when I saw my
cousin II would have a lot of followers
because she does of Skinnygirl she does
have a lot of followers her content the
worst con except Erica Jane obviously
has like a young person running and
premium yeah I think we don't get to see
her that you know it's not her filming
it yeah we're taking the picture it's
all like graphic images put together by
Mikey and the Tia I knew I want to see
like a selfie with like hey guys she
doesn't do that
happy Sunday my lips are like either on
the spectrum of like can barely get a
blurry selfie obviously got a hashtag
I'm showing there aren't any have to
grab a head shake any coloring like
how'd you think without showing their
core your way to premium like even Lisa
banner public she makes like it's like a
Pandora's making her like cards you know
any right you know who weirdly has good
premium content
underrated company Holman you would
never guess it Oh she posts like her
outfits she liked who knows it like
she's she does a good job in tune with
let's go yeah and I think he was have an
intern she often like uses a real camera
that makes so much of the difference but
you don't these folk camera you don't
always have to but like you know just
try yeah it's so easy what else happened
oh so Jack's like really really like
woke up with a moral hangover and like
was so sad the show was it's just
frustrating cuz like we know that
they're together now yeah so like and
they like might be engaged I don't know
he they're not Jack's just she said he
really likes where ring on that finger
if he's engaged if they were engaged she
would be wearing a ring not him yeah
yeah it was really sad I really like
Britney and I just like I want good
things for him like I had want Jax to
like just be the person that we know he
can be because I did so many times and
he's amazing right and he's so loving
always calls me babe but like I'm
annoyed with everyone like getting
involved in his business but like this
is just Karma for all the years he's
been getting involved in everyone's
relationship and I get it but like I
really want everyone to [ __ ] off and
like I'm of the mindset when like the
man cheats on you I'm like you're better
than that like but like I said like if
it happened to me it's never happened to
me God willing a million times never
does but like I would I'd be so brave I
don't know so I can't fault Brittany for
taking him back she's like I want to
come back I love him like I kind of
understand that and just like that's
your decision
let let her prove her wrong let her be
wrong but like leave her alone yeah we
she know what's not in this episode no I
know where was she
I just realized that I don't know who
she not at pucker & pout maybe she was
on the trip with Rob maybe they were
looking at houses maybe they were
hanging in TV maybe they were conceiving
Madison parks poeta it's all happening
that party was cool honestly like as
much as like everyone's giving her [ __ ]
for saying I could hang a TV in seven
minutes like that is pretty cool no I've
hung a TV it's literally take me two
hours no like and that must be so handy
to have someone around the house who can
like do stuff instead of having to wait
for a handyman all right so what we're
both married so she needs to Jewish men
and like that's just not a quality I
guess great that they you know they're
they're good at like making dinner
reservations making jokes but like I'm
terrible and mention ideas you know
what's so funny actually we had this the
other day like one of the lights in our
house went out and like I was like just
natural like I got a light bulb and I
gotta fix it I'm like turning and Ben's
like watching me I'm like you should be
doing this
what do you mean like like care of man
and like it wasn't high up so like I
don't have to get a ladder I was like on
my wall so I would do it like this but
like it didn't even occur to me that
like that's the thing a husband does and
we're we in this group called HG seen me
which is like home decor for all of our
followers and it's a really popular and
the girls keep putting in like oh my
husband just like built this wall and
I'm like looks like I just can't make
the thought of having a husband who
could like build stuff is like a dream
it was so imagine like Rob yeah just
doing some of these girls is not cabin
from the ground up no but he like really
renovated it but these girls in HD seen
me like they put literal like huge like
bureaus I do you like the backsplash
yeah and just did this I'm like what
yeah like we call it TaskRabbit yeah
exhibit okay so of course the first time
I ever use TaskRabbit in my life which
was not really I've used it so many
times it's been a yesterday from
TaskRabbit we've had a data breach
[Music]
couldn't get worse right it's like not
only was my experience not premium but
now my data's out there that's wild yeah
but I just feel like with like credit
card information it's like okay if I see
a charge that's not mine like I'll just
call the credit card company yeah right
sound that crazy yeah but it's not about
that it's more just about like I'm
getting like your oh and steal my
identity yeah well I feel like if you're
a celebrity you can't get your identity
stolen so that's really motivation for
me to like really make it big no for
sure well I think if you are somebody
like there's more people who know about
your identity like if you try to like go
to 7-eleven and be like hammer I carry
there to people who steal your identity
like don't go to like Duane Reade they
do like online shaving it but then like
the credit card companies are really
good about knowing like some credit card
even like one time I was on a dive for
so long that I went to Dylan's Candy Bar
to like splurge and I got fraud
I got fraud at just salad someone once
but like that's really in tune with
what's necessary that's our show
I'm so hungry I literally have not been
able to think about anything else for
the past ten minutes really I'm starving
long day we do we have such a day I'm an
important meetings I'm so excited for
you know it's mean that we're gonna
announce tomorrow yes today
so if you're not in our Morning Show
story basically that's where we put
exclusive content exclusive like
announcements are only not sinful I got
I put the ticket I can't speak English
I put the announcement about my tickets
in there because I just wanted them to
be able to get early access so make sure
you're in our morning shows there's
Facebook group there's a few questions
you have to answer it's not a big deal
if you want to buy tickets to my
Caroline show I will put all the
information on my Instagram I'm very
excited about it make sure you're just
being in tune with what's necessary
because that's what the morning toast is
about you could follow the morning show
us on Facebook on Instagram in the
podcast app on twit no not on Twitter
Facebook instrument YouTube sorry yeah
at the morning toast everywhere I'm
Claudia actually a girl with her job
club with no job if you want to follow
me they're like I really I promise I
won't be upset Jackie I'll show you
Jackie oh problem it's like please
follow me there we will be serving up
Joe I want we should serve up justice
and we should make a toast I want to
serve up justice for Britney okay
justice for Britney from like I hope Jax
to serve justice and I hope that her
friends have left her alone
I completely agree and then a toast I
would like to make a toast to my
Caroline show no it's like so self
congratulatory if I'm doing it no cuz I
want to do something I don't want to do
that um let's make a toast
wow this is hard we should really
pre-plan these no it's because we don't
know what we're gonna talk about during
the show to the toasters what about a
toast to true Thompson oh no I chose to
true Jackson the original true we will
see you guys tomorrow
[Laughter]
you